even on pro-government television
funicaraguans were seen voting in
Sunday's Municipal elections
voting they arrived after a campaign
without rallies electoral events or any
real opposition in polls that observers
say were a farce exiled opposition
leaders called for a boycott
there is a spreading Santa Fe amongst
the people these are possibly the worst
elections we've had in recent years
there is no competition and no Freedom
when more than three hundred thousand
nicaraguans were forced to flee the
country
but some who did vote in the capital
Managua think otherwise
for us nicaraguans these are true
elections here we are demonstrating that
we have the right to vote
president Daniel Ortega sandinista's
National Liberation Front already
controls 141 of the country's 153
municipalities it could govern all of
them after Sunday
and in the past two years most
opposition parties have been outlawed
and their candidates jailed
on Friday the inter-american commission
on human rights denounced Nicaragua
saying it lacked quote the minimum
necessary conditions to hold free and
fair elections
it called on the government to
re-establish Democratic guarantees and
stop the Crackdown that has only
worsened since the police and
paramilitary groups repressed citizen
protest in 2019.
Nicaragua in Nicaragua government forces
killed more than 500 people it is
prohibited to display a national flag in
the street there are more than 250
political prisoners in horrible
conditions more than 3 000 ngos have
been closed even pre-saw being arrested
and in Nicaragua the possibility of
citizen participation in free and
transparent elections has gone we need
International Help
president Ortega and his wife vice
president Rosario mourillo said Sundays
was a vote for peace
but a couple has increasingly employed
authoritarian tactics to keep their grip
on power
exiled nicaraguans took to the streets
in neighboring Costa Rica to protest the
vote
we are demonstrating against the
Electoral fraud that Ortega is trying to
impose on the citizens today
another 100 Civil Society organizations
were forcibly closed on Friday before
the vote as the government gets every
day closer to a single party control of
the country Alessandro Al Jazeera